as a content creator with my own
business online I am normally someone
who works from home but ever since the
corona virus outbreak and the call to
stay indoors not only has the type of
content that I'm producing shifted but
also my workflow has shifted hey
everybody my name is Ashley hey everyone
I'm Lizzy pink hi my name is Koko bossy
and I'm the founder and creator of
millennial calm and I am a blogger and
social media editor based in New York
City I'm a video producer and lifestyle
host and I ran my own media company
normally on a day like this and be going
to the office or checking out my
favorite coffee shop I would be out
shooting content for brands maybe be
taking a client out to lunch but instead
I'm cooped up by myself in my Brooklyn
apartment I've had a lot of privilege
that a lot of other people don't
necessarily get to have which is getting
to work from home it's definitely not
ideal for creatives like me that do most
of our job outdoors often I'm working
with a team of other people if I'm doing
a high-quality video shoot outside of my
apartment sometimes I'll hire a
videographer or an audio expert when it
comes to videographers and photographers
I have totally had to do all of that on
my own
so a lot of what I'm shooting is just
setting up a camera on a tripod or just
leaning it against the windowsill and
shooting it myself at the start of this
it was really tempting to kind of just
continue creating content like normal
but I realized that right now the world
is just not normal and if you just avoid
that and don't talk about it people are
not going to find what you're saying to
be useful or relevant at all the
creating content at home doesn't always
have to be this huge production and I
think that's one of the things that a
lot of creators kind of get stuck doing
like when we are unable to get outside
and create this like amazing extravagant
setup we think that we're like unable to
work at all and that's totally not true
I have my iPhone my vlogging camera
which is a canon g7x and then I also
have my DSLR camera that I tend to use
for some of my bigger brand project I
will always make sure the camera is
my as a Lisette my like hip or waist
level because that's kind of where it
looks at the most flattering I don't
like to go that much lower otherwise it
kind of feels like the camera is looking
at my nose
which is not that great either more and
more recently I've found myself
gravitating towards shooting on my
iPhone I don't have any of my softbox
lights with me so I've just been using
Windows as a source of natural light I
usually have a tripod but since I left
it at my office before the quarantine
happened I've been using a stack of
books on top of a stool this is a okay
if you don't own a tripod like you can
totally improvise with anything that you
have personally I'm focused on doing
video based content because that is a
way for me to diversify my work and
connect with people better it also gives
people more of an idea of how I'm doing
in my house and like kind of what I'm
working on and it makes me feel more
connected to the outside world when it
comes to experimental content I will
definitely without a doubt say that it's
been getting into tik-tok which is kind
of crazy to think about I never thought
that I would be the creator that would
get into tik-tok so I just didn't think
it was a platform for me but I've seen
some really really cool content on there
and it's also kind of cool to play
around with video editing which is
something I've always wanted to be
better at I started using tik-tok just
as a fun outlet for me to dance and it
actually makes me sweat a lot and then
people seem to like the tic-tock stuff
so I created a youtube video tutorial
showing them how to do a tick-tock dance
that I love I'm a savage huh okay I'm
not a dance instructor so I usually work
with dance instructors
and I've also been experimenting with
some quarantine specific content so
cutting my husband's hair in quarantine
and also my morning routine in
quarantine and people seem to be
resonating with that as well been doing
a lot more skincare and beauty I feel
like now is the time to get out there
and experiment with some new products
and stuff and even play around with
makeup because if you mess it up no
one's gonna see it I feel like these
times now I have so much more time to
connect with my audience as easier said
than done depending on the size of your
account but it's important to be extra
responsive to your audience a lot of
people are probably coming to you from a
really anxious and unsure please digital
connection is everything it's one of the
only ways that people are able to stay
connected with their families and
friends that they're not with right now
and honestly it's how people are
maintaining a lifeline and a connection
to the outside world my number one tip
is just finding the tool that like gets
you the closest to your audience that
makes you feel comfortable
one big thing that I've been
experimenting with more is doing
live-streaming when I make my coffee in
the morning and I'm relaxing on my
windowsill I just turn on my live and I
just ask people how they're feeling I've
been loving running polls on my
Instagram stories some of the ways that
I've connected with my audience right
now are by using the sticker tab on
Instagram that's a great way to hear
directly from your audience in response
to a targeted question I use my YouTube
community tab pretty often as a way to
ask questions or to take polls a lot of
people are turning to content right now
to just you know feel a tiny ounce of
normality and if you do have a platform
with an audience that's listening to you
just use it right now to spread some
sort of positivity